- Dicknanigans.
Dicknanigans.
- Sluge.
- Dicknanigans!
("Key & Peele" theme song)
- [Announcer] Ladies and gentlemen,
please turn off your cell
phones and enjoy our production
of "Lunch With Greatness".
- My, my, my, what a beautiful
day in Montgomery, Alabama.
I swear the sun is so hot I nearly melted.
- Indeed, Dr. King, but I
suspect we didn't meet here
to talk about the weather.
- Indeed, brother Malcolm.
Unless, of course, we articulate
that the sun in the country
shines brighter on some
than it does on others.
- Yes, but when the sun does shine on us
it is growing the seeds of revolution.
- That's what I'm talking about.
- I see your point, brother Malcolm,
but do not those same seeds
need to be watered with love?
- [Key] Well, I suppose
that is the subject
of some discussion, Dr. King.
- And I am all for
discussion, brother Malcolm,
unless of course the words devolve
into proclamations of hate.
(audience applauding)
- Well, is that not why we
are here today, Dr. King?
To discuss.
(fly buzzing)
- Yes, brother Malcolm.
And I am confident that as we discuss-
- We are going to
discuss it and discuss it
until I say
that
our people have never resorted to violence
before the white man gave them no choice
but to pay him back in the
only currency he understands.
(audience applauding)
- Brother Malcolm,
is that what you really
have to say at this point
in our lunch?
- Indeed, Dr. King.
Because we didn't land on Plymouth Rock.
Plymouth Rock landed on us!
(audience cheering)
- Okay, well yes, all right.
I've heard you say that before.
I don't know why we're talking about rocks
when in fact it is the flesh
and the bone and the dreams.
I have a dream that someday
our children will be judged
by the content of their character,
not by the color of their skin.
(audience applauding)
- Same for me, same for me.
In fact, I believe that
one day a black man
will become the president of
the United States of America.
(audience applauding)
Hopefully for eight years.
(audience cheering)
Obama 2020.
- Of course eight years,
of course eight years.
That's a given, right?
That's a given.
But in order to get there,
isn't he going to need the help
of our strong, beautiful black women?
(audience cheering)
Gotta respect the sisters!
Gotta respect the sisters.
(audience cheering)
- As Wesley Snipes said in "Passenger 57",
always bet on black.
(audience cheering)
- The west side is the best side!
- Contextualize the whole thing.
- They are a step ahead
of us every single time.
- Dicknanigans.
(dramatic synth music)
(car horn honking)
(car horns honking)
(cars colliding)
(Peele whimpers)
(dramatic synth music)
- Mm hmm. Mm hmm.
- Mm hmm.
- Dicknanigans.
- Amazing.
- I know.
(smooth jazz music)
(Key groans)
(dramatic synth music)
- Dicknanigans.
- It's a dialogue without dialogue.
- Absolutely, I feel
like they're in my head.
("Clair De Lune")
(audience gasps)
(Peele groans)
(dramatic synth music)
- Dicknanigans.
- Wow.
(Peele groans)
- Dicknanigans.
Dicknanigans.
(Key groans)
- Sluge.
- Dicknanigans.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
- Gentlemen.
Exploded Nut Syndrome
is a condition indicated by
the presence of exploded nuts,
which yours are.
By the way, I saw your show last night.
Amazing.
(audience applauding)
- [Usher] Intermission.
- Oh, Othello is my shite!
- Othello is my shite!
- (bleep) yeah.
- Othello, (bleep)!
(Key and Peele making sword sounds)
- (bleep), you dead, white person.
Oh this play doth seem
dope to me, Martinzion.
- Verily, Lashawnio, verily.
Yo, and tis about time
Shakespeare doth scriven the play
that places a brother
amongst the firmaments.
- That's my stite!
- Who's your favorite
character? Mine's Othello.
- Tis mine as well, tis mine as well.
- Because they got Othello as a general.
I'm saying helleth yes.
- And Othello did the beast with two backs
with that comely white maiden
and didst not anyone speaketh against him!
He straight pimping!
- Me thinks things are looking up
for people of the darker hue.
- Damn straight!
♪ Hey, nani, nani,
talking hey, nani, nani ♪
- Oh, Martinzion,
wouldst that I could
borrow a couple of duckets
to purchaseth a capon
from yonder concession?
- Moor please,
you know I can a
concealed Cornish game hen
up on my doublet.
- Ooh, alloweth me to
partake up in this bitch.
- Okay okay. Get in there.
- [Usher] The second
act is about to begin.
- Come on, y'all. Y'all heard the usher.
- If I know Shakespeare,
Othello's bout to kill
everybody up in this bitch.
(horns blowing)
(audience applauding)
Nope, nope, nope!
I hated this play!
- How they gon kill Othello?
Man, that trifling ass Iago.
I knew he was up to something,
they should've killed
him in the first act.
- How they gon kill Othello?
- And then how Othello gon
do himself in with a dagger?
How doth that happen?
- Let me tell you something.
If a brother killed himself
every time he broke up with a white bitch
this world would be bereft of brothers!
- And you'd be talking
to a skull right now.
Where Shakespeare at?
- Shakespeare.
Ooh, ooh, he's right there (indistinct).
Make way. Make way.
(indistinct), make way.
Be gone, (indistinct).
You killed Othello!
- A black man got it going on
and you shuffle off his mortal coil?
- I said unto thee that's a tragedy!
- Oh, tis that not the
troubadour Kanye of the West?
- What, oh, no.
- Truth be told, my lords,
tis not I who penned this dreadful play.
Twas Christopher Marlow.
- Nay, nay, nay, nay, nay.
- Nay, nay, nay, nay.
- Thou already tried to
use that line of argument
when the Jews wanted to kick your ass
after "The Merchant of Venice".
- We doth not purchase it, Slick Willy.
We doth not purchase it.
- Be calm. My good lords.
Will not be long before
another black hero graceth the stage,
and now if you let me
take my leave of you-
- Not so fast.
You gon write that hero now.
- Verily that, (bleep).
(upbeat jazz music)
- That John Shafte is one bad mother-
- Shut that mouth.
- I just speaketh about Shafte.
(dramatic orchestral music)
♪ One at a time. ♪
♪ I put men like you
behind bars everyday ♪
♪ One at a time ♪
♪ Leg or toe ♪
♪ You may take my ears ♪
♪ But cannot lock my soul away ♪
♪ All the years I had to run ♪
♪ So long ago it all began ♪
♪ In the shadows on my shame ♪
♪ But was I ever to blame ♪
♪ Do I let this fight end now ♪
♪ Just to end this life of me ♪
♪ Will the end be welcome now ♪
♪ Will my journey be in vain ♪
♪ I only stole a loaf of bread ♪
♪ All I needed to survive ♪
♪ If I end up in your cell ♪
♪ Why would I have stayed alive ♪
♪ Do I tell him that I love him ♪
♪ Do I tell him of his child ♪
♪ Now where did this bitch come from? ♪
♪ I have no idea ♪
♪ One at a time ♪
♪ Will he ever know his daughter ♪
♪ Will he recognize her eyes ♪
♪ Did you say my daughter? ♪
♪ Yours and mine, one at a time ♪
♪ This song has to happen
on the same block ♪
♪ Now this is just a joke ♪
♪ We can solve all of these issues ♪
♪ If everyone just spoke one at a time ♪
♪ Taking what we can 'cause
things are getting worse ♪
♪ Taking what we can from
every pocket and purse ♪
♪ (indistinct) have come ♪
♪ One at at time ♪
♪ The years destroyed the man ♪
♪ She knew before we parted ♪
♪ And more and more and
more we (indistinct) ♪
♪ We will die, I will die ♪
♪ Years they pass, can we speak ♪
♪ One ♪
♪ At ♪
♪ A time ♪
♪ Why are we all facing the same way? ♪
- [General] Is the city on
fire? What's with all the smoke?
Oh now we're all ears.
Great.
("Key & Peele" theme song)